[music]
Stephen Pacala:
Welcome to the Princeton Environmental Institute.
I'm the director of the institute, Steve Pacala.
Stephen Pacala:
PEI is the entity at Princeton that manages environmental
education and research on a constellation of topics in over
Stephen Pacala:
25 departments from science and technology to policy,
the arts, humanities and social sciences.
Stephen Pacala:
At PEI, undergraduate students can take part in a certificate
program and many opportunities for research, including
Stephen Pacala:
internships, senior theses and multi-year research programs
that are best thought of as super theses.
Stephen Pacala:
We have a world-class faculty. A significant number of people
whom you've learned about in the press or in coursework outside
Stephen Pacala:
of Princeton are on the faculty here, such as Dan Rubenstein,
the animal behaviorist;
Stephen Pacala:
Franquois Morel, the oceanographer; and Catherine Peters, civil engineer.
Students work hands-on with these faculty members
Stephen Pacala:
and other top experts.
These range from policy expert Michael Oppenheimer, who for
Stephen Pacala:
over 30 years has been one of the most visible spokespeople
about climate change;
Stephen Pacala:
to Michael Bender whose work on greenhouse gases and climate
has established one of the most convincing links between
Stephen Pacala:
fossil fuels and warming;
to Peter Singer, one of the world's most distinguished ethicists.
Stephen Pacala:
Our faculty comes from over 25 departments, and we
cover the most important environmental issues.
Stephen Pacala:
We have particular expertise on global climate change with
literally hundreds of scientists, engineers and policy experts.
Stephen Pacala:
These include ecosystem ecologist Lars Hedin, chemist
and fuel cell expert Andy Bocarsly, oceanographer and
Stephen Pacala:
climate modeler Jorge Sarmiento, and alternative
energy expert Craig Arnold.
Stephen Pacala:
We collaborate closely with the nearby NOAA Geophysical Fluid
Dynamics Laboratory, which builds the climate models
Stephen Pacala:
that guide U.S. policy.
Princeton is the only top-tier University that builds
Stephen Pacala:
cutting-edge climate models.
Our faculty includes biodiversity experts such as
Stephen Pacala:
David Wilcove and Simon Levin.
We also have a remarkable concentration of oceanographers
Stephen Pacala:
and marine biologists, such as Bess Ward and Danny Sigman.
PEI is home to leading experts on environmental pollutants,
Stephen Pacala:
energy technology and epidemic disease, such as air pollution
expert Denise Mauzerall, energy expert Rob Socolow, and
Stephen Pacala:
healthcare expert Chris Paxson.
The core of the educational offering is the certificate program.
Stephen Pacala:
We offer three core courses that integrate science,
policy and technology, and a large number of more specialized courses.
Stephen Pacala:
The PEI education is experiential and hands-on.
We spent lots of time outside working in the rough.
Stephen Pacala:
The undergraduate program culminates an environmental
thesis, supported by an extensive grant program.
Stephen Pacala:
We believe in the Princeton formula of a
disciplinary education.
Stephen Pacala:
But we know that to solve intractable problems around the
world, we need to collaborate across disciplinary lines.
Stephen Pacala:
We are committed to providing the opportunity to study
environmental subjects, making a difference now and still
Stephen Pacala:
complete a major in any traditional field.
We hope that you'll get involved.
Stephen Pacala:
The world needs for you to get involved.
Please do not hesitate to contact us by e-mail or, even better,
Stephen Pacala:
to drop by our headquarters at Guyot Hall.
Do check out our website.
Stephen Pacala:
It contains lots of information that will help you get started.
[music]